elle continue avec notre grand entretien
ne recevant ce soir kahina bahlul et les
islamologues théologienne première femme
imams de france elle publie mon islam ma
liberté elle prône un islam libéral
on verra avec elle d'ailleurs ce qu'elle
entend par là et on lui demandera ce
qu'elle pense de cette loi contre le
séparatisme voté au sénat et que
certains trouvent islamophobe avant de
l'accueillir faisant le point sur les
mesures les plus importantes les plus
fortes les plus marquantes qui ont été
donc adopté au sénat pour lutter contre
le séparatisme sujet bilan signé marion
delpech le sénat continue de durcir
considérablement le projet de loi
séparatisme
l'amendement dit unef initiée par les
sénateurs les républicains alexandra
burke et aux fantasmes et stéphane le
rudulier a été adopté jeudi à
l'unanimité permettant de dissoudre les
associations faisant des réunions non
mixte aura 6 et adoption à l'unanimité
aussi de l'amendement permettant au
maire d'interdire les drapeaux étrangers
lors des mariages
une interdiction qui s'appliquerait si
le texte n'est pas retoquée par les
députés dans la salle des mariages et à
proximité de l'hôtel de ville
les sénateurs ont également voté
l'interdiction du port du voile par les
mineurs dans l'espace public ainsi que
l'interdiction des femmes voilées lors
des sorties scolaires
enfin le patron des sénateurs les
républicains n'est pas en reste avec
l'adoption de la proposition
d'interdiction des listes communautaires
aux élections
le sénat a adopté l'article samuel pâtit
sanctionnant la mise en danger d'autrui
par la diffusion d'informations
personnelles au cours d'une séance
marquée par un affrontement entre le
garde des sceaux et l'opposition qui
craint pour la liberté de la presse et
on est passé d'un système de
cautionnement à un système de cause de
contrôle a posteriori c'est à dire que
si il ya un acte diffamatoire alors qui
conque 70 femmes et peut attaquer la
presse concernant le renforcement de la
neutralité dans le monde du sport
l'amendement le plus emblématique vise à
interdire le port de signes religieux
ostensibles pour la participation aux
événements sportifs et aux compétitions
sur le volet de l'enseignement enfin
plusieurs dispositions ont été adoptées
l'interdiction des prières dans les
couloirs des universités la lutte contre
les actions de propagande perturbant la
tenue de conférences
l'interdiction dans la loi des listes
communautariste aux élections étudiantes
en force sur l'école en famille
l'hémicycle s'est opposé à
l'autorisation préalable souhaitée par
le gouvernement
après deux semaines d'examen du texte
par les sénateurs le rapporteur stéphane
pieds-noirs s'inquiète du compromis
qu'il faudra trouver avec les députés
ça va être évidemment compliqué et
ensuite à l'examen jeu je compte
vraiment sur la sagesse des députés pour
dire 'attendez regarder entre les
objectifs affichés par le président de
la république et la réalité de ce texte
tel que vous nous l'avez livré au cédrat
ya un grand écart que nous avons essayé
de combler et si aucun accord n'est
trouvé entre sénateurs et députés
l'assemblée nationale statuera en
dernier ressort et allons plus loin dans
l'entretien avec nous ce soir cahier
nabaloum bienvenue à vous vous êtes
devenu en 2019 la première femme à
occuper la fonction d'imam en france
vous raconter votre parcours et vous
faites part de votre vision de l'islam
dans ce livre mon islam ma liberté le
voilà on va y revenir je voudrais
d'abord votre regard sur tout ce qui a
été modifié voté au sénat après deux
semaines de débats et notamment sur ce
qui concerne le voile interdiction du
voile pour les mineurs dans l'espace
public interdiction du voile pour les
accompagnatrices colère comment vous
voyez tout cela et bien écoutez je
trouve qu'il ya certaines mesures qui
sont tout à fait les bienvenus notamment
sur la question du voile des mineurs
je trouve qu'il faut effectivement
protéger les filles les petites filles
les mineurs qui n'ont pas encore l'âge
de décider de choisir si elles veulent
porter le voile ou pas et je crois que
justement le danger de ces idéologie
fondamentaliste c'est de faire du corps
de la femme un enjeu politique
d'ailleurs j'en parle aussi dans mon
livre je crois qu'il faut absolument
protéger les femmes contre cela il faut
redonner à la femme la liberté de
pouvoir choisir et il se trouve que
quand on est mineur on ne peut pas
choisir vous mettez dans le même panier
j'allais dire la petite fille de 10 ans
et l'adolescent de 15 16 ans qui fait le
choix de cacher sa chevelure parce
qu'elle peut considérer que c'est une un
atout une coquetterie qu'elle veut
réserver à son futur mari pour vous
c'est pas un choix même à 15 16 ans ça
ne peut pas être un choix pour vous non
je pense que ça peut être un choix
lorsque effectivement je pense qu'on ne
peut pas du tout mettre sur le même plan
une petite fille de 10 ans dans un an
qui ne comprend même pas ce qu'est le
voile quel est le sens de ce voile et
parce que le voile c'est aussi le sens
qu'on lui donne et moi je respecte tout
à fait les femmes qui choisissent de le
porter parce que consciemment elles
choisissent de le porter lui donne un
sens spirituel un sens personnel et
individuel
mais ce qui est gênant par contre c'est
lorsque cet habit ce vêtement devient un
enjeu d'une idéologie politique
intégristes et que des jeunes filles de
14 15 ans à un moment donné veille
essayé cela parce qu'elles ont besoin
d'affirmer une identité peut-être
pourquoi pas elle se cherche je crois
que ça ne sert à rien non plus de faire
des polémiques qui ne font que renforcer
cette problématique et aussi de leur
rejet aussi d'une certaine
voilà deux
de certaines lois de la république ou
d'un certain cadre je crois qu'il faut
plutôt les accompagner mais en tout cas
respecter aussi la liberté de chacune de
gérer son corps comme l envie alors il
n'y a pas que le voile bien sûr on vient
de le voir dans le sujet de marion le
sénat a voté l'interdiction du burkini
des liste communautaire des certificats
de virginité des prières dans les
universités je vous ai vu réagir
d'ailleurs pendant le sujet pour
certains politiques de gauche c'est de
l'islamophobie pur et dur vous êtes
d'accord avec ça je ne pense pas que ce
soit de l'islamophobie pur et dur je
crois que il y a réellement un
intégrisme islamiste qu'il faut qu'il
faut absolument contrôler il y à des
idéologies cela mist qui sévissent
malheureusement partout dans le monde
depuis très longtemps moi j'ai connu ça
en algérie dans les années 90 ce n'est
pas nouveau absolument pas nouveau et je
crois qu'il ne faut pas être naïf
vis-à-vis de ces de ces mouvements là ce
sont des mouvements politiques qui
veulent arriver au pouvoir et
prendre le pouvoir politique en
diffusant une idéologie en
instrumentalisant la religion en vérité
et c'est pour ça que voilà j'adresse
aussi ce message à tous tous les jeunes
musulmans pour leur dire essayer de
comprendre un petit peu mieux votre
religion et puis la religion finalement
est plutôt une conviction qui se vit
dans la sphère intime dans et puis c'est
d'abord une spiritualité
donc oui il faut avoir conscience qu'il
y à cette instrumentalisation politique
de l'islam et il fait cela doit passer
par des lois des interdictions vous
pensez que ça peut marcher ou qu'au
contraire ça pourrait braquet alors
quelques fois oui ça peut braqué je
pense qu'il faut faire très très
attention justement il faut arriver à
trouver l'équilibré entre les
interdictions qui sont nécessaires comme
par exemple la protection des mineurs
par exemple ces mineurs qui sont
soustraits à l'éducation dans l'école de
la république ça c'est absolument
inacceptable
il faut probablement passer par des lois
pour ça mais je ne pense pas qu'il soit
nécessaire de tout de tout faire passer
par des lois et de tout réglementer
je crois que beaucoup passera aussi par
l'éducation et la prise de conscience de
ce qu'est de ce que sont ces idéologies
politiques vous dirais qu'il ya un
climat quand même
islamophobe en france où pas ces
dernières années vous le ressentez vous
en tout cas il y à une dessine une
hystérisation du débat dès qu'il s'agit
de parler de l'islam ces dernières
années ça tout le monde le sent et le
voit on ne peut pas le cacher on le vit
malheureusement presque au quotidien
c'est déplorable c'est triste que l
islam qui est une d'abord une religion
une spiritualité deviennent à ce point
un sujet qu'il y vend on en est arrivé
là d'après vous qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi cette défiance vis-à-vis
de cette religion et qui est une
défiance qui a fait suite à des
attentats islamistes qui a priori
doivent être complètement dissocié de
oui oui tout à fait alors oui ce qui
s'est passé c'est que justement cette
instrumentalisation politique jules joue
sur cette confusion en tentant d'asseoir
leur idéologie politique sur un message
religieux
en créant donc la confusion dans
l'esprit des musulmans et puis cette
confusion ces temps malheureusement
lorsqu'on voit des attentats terroristes
à la télévision et que ces attentats
sont commis au nom d'allah akbar ça crée
beaucoup de confusion et malheureusement
d'un autre côté aussi les gens ne sont
pas toujours
nous ne faisons pas dans la nuance
malheureusement nous aujourd'hui nous
avons tendance à fonctionner dans la
vraie vie comme nous fonctionnons sur
les réseaux sociaux où il est
effectivement plus facile dahir que de
réfléchir
on n'est plus dans d'envoi la dent dans
le propos posé réfléchi que des choux
toutes les mouvances islamistes sont en
train de gagner sont en train de nous
diviser soyons très morcelé notre
société c'est ce qui c'est ce qui est
déplorable et vraiment c'est ce qui
m'attriste beaucoup moi et beaucoup de
musulmans je pense parce que voilà on
est finalement dès qu'on parle d'islam
aujourd'hui on est dans des stéréotypes
et
on croit que tous les musulmans ce sont
des de potentiels terroristes alors que
la grande majorité des musulmans sont
complètement intégrés dans la société
française vivre leur religion de façon
complètement apaisé contribuent à
construire ce pays au quotidien
nous avons des cadres supérieurs nous
avons des médecins nous avons des gens
simples qui qui qui vivent au quotidien
de manière tout à fait apaisée leur
religion c'est intéressant vous avez
prononcé le mot intégrer ce que dans le
contexte de ce vote de au parlement
revient le débat sur les questions
d'assimilation et ou d'intégration en
chemin on a fait une chronique dans le
monde je vous cite quelques lignes face
aux craintes de l'islam politique la
notion d'assimilation fait son retour
développé sous la troisième république
comme condition nécessaire à la
naturalisation cette notion à la
différence de celle d'intégration
implique l'abandon des différences pour
se fondre dans le creuset national
je vous vois réagir il faut pas en
arriver là je veux vraiment aller à
l'extrême de
d'une logique qui ne semble pas du tout
souhaitable on ne peut pas
l'intégration ou vivre en harmonie dans
une société ne veut pas dire uniformité
nous avons tous nos identités
par contre je pense que là où il faut
aller il faudrait aller vers plus de
reconnaissance de nos identités
multiples composite et ne pas à signer
les gens à leur identité dans qui dans
l'heure sa dimension simplement
religieuse ou à ses origines
et c'est cette prise de conscience je
crois qu'il doit se faire dans les deux
sens fin c'est à dire de la part des
français musulmans mais aussi des
politiques
il faut sortir de ces clivages et de
cette polarisation de la société
parlons de vous de votre parcours on
découvre donc dans ce livre mon islam ma
liberté vous êtes la première femme
imams de france
pourquoi comment en êtes vous arrivé là
eh bien ça a été tout un cheminement ce
n'est pas quelque chose que j'ai décidée
comme ça en me réveillant un matin
c'était à tout un parcours j'ai d'abord
connu l'islam dans ma famille en algérie
et puis après j'ai connu la décennie
noire malheureusement qui a remis
beaucoup de choses en question dans ma
tête d'adolescentes de jeunes adultes
qui après je suis arrivé en france
j'avais pris un petit peu mais mes
distances avec la religion mais jamais
avec la spiritualité et c'est en vivent
un drame le drame de la perte de mon
père que je me suis tourné je re
découvert la spiritualité musulmane à
travers le soufisme et là j'ai compris
que l'islam était en fait beaucoup plus
riches
on peut avoir une compréhension beaucoup
plus profonde et spirituelle de l'islam
mais en s'intéressant à la spiritualité
vous vous déclarez donc être imams de
france
est ce que c'est ça a été compliqué
c'est compliqué ce que vous êtes
contestée est ce que vous êtes menacés
insultés dix ans c'est toujours
compliqué pour les femmes
ce n'est jamais simple bien sûr oui j'ai
au départ j'ai été plus que contestait
pas par tout le monde a bien sûr mais
certains certains qui croient être les
gardiens du temple
voilà ont cru bon de m'insulter de me
menacer même en 2019 j'avais reçu des
menaces sur les réseaux sociaux
mais ce qui est déplorable c'est tout
cela en fait provient d'une ignorance de
ce qu'est l'islam de sa tradition de ces
textes c'est là où on voit que le
fondamentalisme religieux a réussi à
faire de l'islam une religion très
dogmatique mais aussi très simpliste
c'est à dire qu'on a une approche de la
religion très très simple
aujourd'hui tout passe malheureusement
pas internet les réseaux sociaux et il
n'ya plus d'études approfondies
le grand mérite et redit pas une femme
détriment non le grande l'interdît
absolument pas à la femme d'être
immeuble est d'ailleurs le courant ne
parle pas du tout de cette fonction de
l'imamat c'est une fonction qui a été
créée plus tardivement pour pour gérer
le culte musulman mais le corps on en
parle absolument pas en tout cas pas de
cette fonction il en parle autrement
comme modèle ou comme livre par exemple
et puis après on trouve dans la
tradition musulmane des cas un cas de
femmes d'une femme qui aurait été
désigné par le prophète lui-même est
souvent souvent cette tradition
prophétique est complètement méconnu et
en fait c'est là où il faut prendre
conscience aussi des lectures qui ont
été fait jusque là qui sont des lectures
très partiel très masculine très
influencé par le prisme patriarcale et
aujourd'hui ce que je dis à travers mon
livre c'est que il faut absolument que
les femmes seraient appropriées aussi la
lecture de ses textes et qu'elles
prennent toute leur place et qu'elles
aient voix au chapitre parce que pour
l'instant vous n'êtes pas reconnue par
les instances officielles musulmane
c'est bien ça je ne suis pas reconnu
nous ne sommes pas reconnus par les
instances officielles musulmane et ce
qui est déplorable c'est que
voilà de temps en temps quand j'en vois
que l'état français aussi par là avec
ses instances et bien les femmes
on a l'impression que les femmes
musulmanes n'existe pas je trouve cela
très très vexant voilà j'ai moi j'ai
envie de dire que les femmes musulmanes
existe nous voulons aussi avoir une
parole et pouvoir représenter notre
voilà des français musulmans dans l'or
entièreté elle pose problème ces
instances officielles musulmane avec
lesquels justement le gouvernement a
tenté de discuter pour les faire signer
une charte on sait à quel point ça a été
compliqué elle pose problème c'est
inspiré trois lames je pense que toute
la question de la représentativité de
l'islam aujourd'hui enfants en france
pose problème parce que d'abord elle est
construite sur le mètre carré mosquée ce
qui est juste incroyable je ne comprend
pas comment on a pu fonder cette
représentativité sur le mètre carré
mosquée et on voit aujourd'hui cette
course au gigantisme dans la
construction des mosquées
parce que certains l'ont compris et où
on voit l'ingérence de ces pays
étrangers qui met beaucoup d'argent
justement pour construire des deux
grands bâtiments dans ce sens alors que
nous par exemple les musulmans les qui
essayons de faire émerger un islam de
france et non un islam en france nous
avons énormément de mal à trouver des
financements à trouver un lieu
et voilà et donc le gouvernement
continue par contre travailler avec ces
institutions dans des schémas absolument
archaïque qui ne représente en réalité
que d'islam consulaires c'est à dire
l'islam des pays étrangers et moi la
question que je pose c'est nous les
musulmans de france en france qui
voulant vivre notre islam en harmonie
avec les valeurs démocratiques de la
république française où sommes nous
est-ce que pourquoi nous ne sommes pas
pris en compte pourquoi on ne parle pas
avec nous justement vous parliez de
l'étranger je voudrais vous montrer une
image qui nous vient de l'étranger
justement elle est en train de faire le
tour des télés du monde entier et même
de provoquer un incident diplomatique
c'est la mise à l'écart est donc
l'humiliation de la présidente de la
commission européenne ursula von der
leyen ça se passe mardi dernier à ankara
regardez lors d'une visite officielle
aucune chaîne n'est prévu pour elle
alors qu'il y en a bien une pour le
président du conseil européen charles
michel et le président turc erdogan elle
a fini par s'asseoir sur un canapé en
retrait des deux hommes alors ça on
appelle ça le sofa gates que 17 images
pour vous peut-être d'ailleurs de la
turquie d'erdogan
je trouve cette image extrêmement
choquant
moi je
je pense qu'il aurait dû cette
délégation aurait dû repartir tout de
suite et
il n'aurait pas dû rester mais quel
manque de respect pour pour pour les
femmes et alors que nous sommes dans en
europe
nous sommes dans des pays qui respectant
l'égalité femme homme ou voilà les
femmes se sont battues pour acquérir des
droits et la dpi ou enfin je veux pas
parler d'un pays parce que en turquie il
y à des musulmans très respectueux et
puis beaucoup de musulmans sont très
respectueux des femmes
mais là le problème je pense qu'ils sont
d'aider certains hommes politiques comme
erdogan par exemple là il ya clairement
un manque de respect vis-à-vis vis-à-vis
de cette femme c'est ça l'islam
politique d'erdogan qu'il essaie de
faire entrer en france puisqu'on a
maintenant des dossiers des services de
renseignement qui ont été remis à
l'elysée qui montre à quel point leur
dos d'âne veut essayer de l'influencer
ce qui se passe en france et le peuple
musulman en france vous l'observez aussi
oui bien sûr écouter dans les
financements de mosquées en mai mais oui
mais pourquoi ils ne feraient pas ils
ont très bien compris de toute façon
tous ces leaders politiques qui
instrumentalisent la religion et qu'ils
ont compris la fragilité de nos systèmes
démocratiques
et puis le retrait de l'état de du du
domaine religieux parce qu'on est un
état laïc et il ya la laïcité à la
française est très particulière aussi il
faut le dire ces pays là entre l'entrée
très bien compris et il est à partir du
moment où ils ont trouvé une porte il
s'engouffre et ils l'utilisent à
l'extrême le la turquie est le principal
je sais pas si vous allez me le
confirmer fournisseur d'imam
en france oui oui oui je crois que la
turquie elle prend un des principaux il
ya aussi le maroc et l'algérie
mais ce qui est inquiétant avec la
turquie c'est que la turquie ces
dernières années en tout cas erdogan a
pris un tournant politique qui
instrumentalisent la religion musulmane
et qui propage un islam c'est connu
plutôt l'islam des frères musulmans qui
est plutôt une idéologie politique
exprimée c'est comment vous êtes formé
vous en tant qu'imam femme ou pas
comment vous est de former comment
fonctionne la mosquée dans laquelle vous
officiez et bien alors moi je me suis
formé déjà dans mon enfance j'ai grandi
en algérie donc à l'école
l'état algérien n'est pas laïque donc à
l'école publique algérienne on étudie il
y a
un catéchisme musulmans jusqu'au lycée
puis après j'ai fait des études de droit
où j'ai étudié justement le le statut
où j'ai étudié le droit de la famille
algérienne qui est complètement inspiré
du droit musulman
et puis donc en fait ce qui m'a permis
d'avoir cette vision de l'islam enseigne
et dans les pays musulmans qui reste
très dogmatique malheureusement et puis
lorsque j'ai décidé en 2015 de m'engager
j'ai décidé de reprendre des études à
l'école pratique des hautes études
c'est une grande école de recherche
française qui émane de la sorbonne j'ai
décidé donc l'aja doit on adopter enfin
on adopte à dans cette école de
recherche
la méthodologie de la méthode
historico-critique l'étude de la
religion à travers les sciences humaines
et sociales
et si les téléspectateurs veulent en
savoir plus je les appelle donc à lire
votre livre mon islam ma liberté merci
infiniment kelly navale houle d'avoir
été notre invité ce soir dans
l'entretien